hey guys Ryan right here I literally
about two days ago finished Entourage is
the first time I watch the entire series
I [ __ ] bald at the end of that
episode man [ __ ] that last episode had
me going if you guys haven't seen
Entourage I'm not gonna ruin it for you
and surprisingly I mean a lot of people
like people that come close with who
have never seen Entourage it is one of
the best shows I've ever seen loved the
characters Jeremy Piven is irreplaceable
you gotta watch the [ __ ] show it
ended with a kind of teaser for a movie
in a way so yeah I'm excited I'm really
[ __ ] excited to watch this
movie studio I want you to stop
I gave you 100 million dollars you
agreed to not go over because you said I
couldn't direct unless we agreed it's
like what a girl asks if you want to
bang her hot sister course you say no if
you really believes you mean it though
what is he doing here
Wow
it's many girl for lucky out of that
anymore my co-financier do you see these
crazy
I'm so excited I finished Entourage
recently so I don't have to wait many
years like everyone else for this movie
bunch of losers you know I've watched
the show Entourage and I'd wonder like
how [ __ ] did they get all this money for
this show like there's a lot of
expensive [ __ ] in that show all the time
now it makes me wonder like how much
bigger they will go for an actual film
it's not like an action-packed plotters
they were like it's bigger and badder
but in a way you kind of feel like with
Entourage it could be bigger and badder
I like how they're picking up the story
like where we left it off from our a
studio ahead now and I like how Vince
wants a job where he can direct it to
it's gonna be fun to watch a up close
real personal struggle because in the
end it tends to work out for them and
that's okay but the struggle is always
so intense as oh it's always so much fun
to watch Jeremy Piven I hope if this
movie is great that he gets recognized
come Oscar consideration because that
performance on Entourage is Academy
Award worthy it's just great to see
everyone come together for this movie I
feel like if this does well they'll get
a lot more adaptations into cinema you
know cuz there's a lot of great shows on
TV that could make a great feature film
I mean the problem that you tend to
encounter though is you get a whole
season to explore the characters and let
a plot really play out with Entourage
you know it's a movie so they're not
gonna get 12 episodes to really flush
the story out they have to condense it
now so I make sure see to see how they
tell a feature film story cuz they're
great at telling the whole season but
see like a 90 minutes a 2-hour piece
that's gonna be [ __ ] interesting
anyway guys thanks for time that trailer
was out so looking forward to that film
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the reel rejects you can
follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
social networks where I am starting to
wonder if dick pics are getting boring
and I should post pictures of my [ __ ]
but honestly I don't have the
like an [ __ ] I want to forget surgery
for my [ __ ] it was better Christian
Hernandez hey I'd like a shout-out
please you guys are my favorite reactors
and I specifically enjoy watching you
Ryan
dan Lauren and Katie react okay
Christian Hernandez I will gladly give
you a shout out for you liking us
reactors I want to see what you look
like though buddy Christian you are
obviously a little boy so I have to keep
this a little bit pg-13 in case your
parents are watching but if I were to
give you a piece of advice it would be
find out right now if you're gay or
straight just really think about it you
know it's better to find out when you're
young and embrace it now and then by the
time you're 18 you're gonna be boning a
bunch of other guys but if you're
straight think about it now get that
confidence gonna be boning a bunch of
girls a Christian remember you are a
Christian so the Lord Jesus will help
you have sex with whoever you want to
have sex